you know there was more evidence today
of the impact that rising prices are
beginning to have thanks to the weakness
of sterling since last June's referendum
vote UK retail sales fell by 0.4% on
unlike for like basis last month
compared with February last year while
over the three months to February
non-food sales also fell by 0.4% and
that's the first quarterly decline for
more than five years
those figures were compiled for the
British Retail Consortium by KPMG whose
head of retail Paul Martin joins us and
Tim Rycroft is Corporate Affairs
Director at the food and drink
Association which today reported rapidly
declining confidence among its members
due to price rises and it's calling for
help from the Chancellor in tomorrow's
budget Paul let me start with you it's
this conclusive proof then that consumer
confidence is weakening good evening in
yes we are seeing the first signs of
consumer spending slowing down as our
reports with the BRC show today are
there any areas of non-food that are
bucking the trend at all I'm in half
term Cola in February for example it is
interesting you say that specifically
the furniture category actually did
pretty well over the trading period we
reported on but that is actually quite
normal a number of other categories had
quite a tough time are we overdoing the
doom and gloom I mean I was looking back
to 2011 when we last saw fall like this
and on that occasion we had falling
crisis we had disinflation now we've got
inflation I mean it's not as bad as it
was in 2011 is it overdoing the doom and
gloom it's tough it is not impossible
out there I think what is really
important to emphasize though we are
seeing a perfect storm out there in the
market we are seeing the devaluation of
sterling we are seeing a business rate
conversation that has been all over the
headlines we are seeing the national
living wage we are seeing the
apprenticeship levy to come into for
which and very soon and that really is
resulting with some significantly
increased pressures to the sector but in
fairness our consumers not behaving nota
CLE here I mean they were all told
towards the end of last year prices were
going to go up in the new year there was
evidence Simon Amin but talking to
people I said James at Dixon's Carphone
he said there was evidence of people
bringing forward purchases from now into
last autumn logically that seems have
been what's happened isn't it
partly some consumers have definitely
reacted that way but the consumer is
there is no one-size-fits-all and some
consumers would have brought purchases
forward but in certain categories you
don't buy things months and months ahead
so we are definitely seeing the
pressures being translated from the high
street into the consumers pockets well
Tim let me bring you in at this point
why you all members so downbeat right
now I think there's two things I think
in the real world that we've just heard
about conditions are very tough
two-thirds of our members are saying
their margins are being squeezed 40%
saying they're feeling more gloomy than
they were in October I think partly
that's also due to the fact that we're
in a continued period of uncertainty and
where we're now waiting for article 50
to be triggered so that we can actually
move into a time when we start to
resolve some of these outstanding issues
around immigration and trade hoping to
see in the budget that tomorrow well I
think there are two really important
things that we'd like to see the first
is help for exports so we had a great
year for exports in 2016 20 billion
pound barrier broken for the first time
for food and drink but still only one in
five food and drink companies export so
we'd love to see support particularly
for small and medium sized businesses to
help them understand how they can crack
export markets that would make a really
big difference we look across the Irish
Sea the Irish government does this very
well for example there's also export
promotion help in Scotland and Wales so
we'd love to see UK food and drink
really get that boost and you know put
it to Tim I mean again are you not
overdoing the doom and gloom slightly if
I look elsewhere new report nearly two
thirds of your members expect as he
sells in the UK grow over coming months
and the same number see sales outside
that e the UK growing this well I mean
that isn't too bad it's absolutely not
I think our industry is incredibly
resourceful and resilient they're
looking for opportunity so where export
where people have imported ingredients
they're now looking for domestic
suppliers that's a whole new opportunity
for domestic food producers if they
haven't been exporting much they're
seeing that as an opportunity they're
always looking for new ways to to find a
way through these difficulties and what
about this young man you touched earlier
on on the price war with the
supermarkets I mean interestingly though
we are still seeing some prefer prices
falling I mean things like come
eggsontour
and bacon understand
it's quite a mixed picture today isn't
it of some commodities that have gone up
and some gone down I think we're still
expecting though over the course of 2017
that food price inflation will become
more general people will have to get
used to that and we've seen today that
there's market share of the discounters
has gone up and I think that's because
customers consumers are now actually
shopping around much more actively than
perhaps they used it I should I should
make them make advantage of carpet cheek
R&R and now while I can that well what
are your members hoping to see from the
retail is hoping to see from the budget
to one you touched on business rate so
there are other things that you're
hoping that the government may weigh
back on I mean touch on the levy there I
think there'll be a number of points
that the retailers will hope that these
will be addressed tomorrow but obviously
the business rate conversation is top of
mind will there be a strategic answer to
that question potentially not there will
likely be some tactical conversations
but the industry is undergoing a
significant structural change and that
really does need to be addressed by the
government going forward we are seeing a
significant increase again as our data
showed today of online penetration more
and more sales are actually being
generated through digital channels and
that is a channel that is not really
being addressed in this conversation at
the moment and so the onward march to
online continues unabated them not
unabated so that's another important
point in the data that we broadcast
today we have seen a slowdown of the
growth in online but it is becoming an
ever-increasing channel for UK retail
whilst at the same time we shouldn't
forget that nearly 80 percent of all
sales are still generated through stores